[Musique]
les fêtes de fin année sont
traditionnellement des fêtes sociales et
famille et cela vient réinterroger notre
rapport à la famille ce qui peut être
difficile pour certains quand tout se
passe bien ben les gens sont heureux et
passent de bonnes fête néanmoins quand
les liens sont distendu ou que les
rapports sont conflictuels cela peut
être plus
difficile
les fêtes de fin d'année sont devenu
principalement une fête
commerciale qui vient réveiller aussi
notre lien social et avec des disparités
tant qu'au choix des cadeaux et aux
possibilités de chacun tout le monde
n'aura pas le téléphone dernier cri au
pied du sapin et tout le monde ne pourra
pas s'offrir les mêmes ma pour Noël la
solitude est particulièrement difficile
pour certaines personnes qui n'ont pas
privoisé leur propre solitude qui ne
sont pas à l'aise avec et de voir les
autres par comparaison tout simplement
euh ça peut rendre les choses difficiles
puisque ça les renvoie à leur propre
isolement alors que tout le monde fait
la fête à
côté on peut avoir accès à différentes
techniques qui peuvent être par exemple
la méditation où vous pouvez prendre des
moments où vous allez être calme
simplement pour vous détendre et vous
reconnecter à votre souffle vous pouvez
aussi écrire un petit journal intime en
cette période qui est particulièrement
propice à l'introspection afin
d'explorer vos pensées et vos émotions
et enfin ben il peut être bon d'aller se
promener dans la nature de se ressourcer
dans la nature même si on est en plein
hiver c'est aussi une dimension qui nous
permet de nous reconnecter à notre être
[Musique]
profond